I've been through the toughest times
with my family but I'm still standing it
was kind of tough knowing that sometimes
I work so hard and everybody else and I
wasn't saying I wasn't reaping the
benefits of it and I wasn't I mean
people just always say that it's cool
you're top three that's cool and a lot
of people got on me for crying in front
of on national TV but we wanted
something that bad it's just like I
didn't care you know we talked about the
end result if it's not where it should
be then it's a failure when something
good happens to you I don't know about
you guys but I tend to look back to what
brought me here he's an American
professional basketball player for the
Oklahoma City Thunder of the NBA he's
won an NBA Most Valuable Player Award
for NBA scoring titles and the Rookie of
the Year award he's been selected to six
all-nba teams and seven all-star teams
he's Kevin Durant and here's my take on
his top ten rules for success I come
from I come from a small county outside
of Washington DC called PG County meet
my mom my brother we moved so many
different places growing up it's not
like a box felt like it was no getting
out
I love basketball so much I love
planning I just never thought I would
make it to college
NBA we're standing up here today and
find you guys a big NBA MVP so many
people believed in me when I didn't
believe in myself so many people doubted
me and motivated me every single day to
be Who I am I feel so many times and got
back up
I've been through the toughest times
with my family team but I'm still
standing I continue to put the ball in
his hand
ah
big old chopper hawk
it was kind of tough knowing that
sometimes I work so hard and everybody
else and I wasn't saying I wasn't
reaping the benefits of it and I wasn't
I wasn't getting any better as quickly
as I wanted to but I stayed patient and
I was one big thing for me is knowing
when to stay patient that everything is
gonna come around and I think that uh
you know with that patience I gained as
a kid it's helping me in the NBA right
now so you know for me it's just you
know always always working hard and
always trying to get better and knowing
that I can get better knowing it you
know I didn't get to him I'm not there
where I want to be yet so I have a long
ways to go spin move scoops it up off
the wind oh my goodness
oh the two times scoring champ showing
you why Kevin this is your quote I've
been second my whole life I was a second
best player in high school second pick
in the draft second in the MVP voting
three times I came in second in the
finals I'm tired of being second I'm not
going to settle for that
I'm done with it stand by that
definitely I means people just always
say that it's cool you top three that's
cool it's alright to be I talked to me
player in the world as autism they gives
up to people in this way need to be top
three that's pretty cool man I'm just
tired of something for that tired of
saying it tired of hearing it Westbrook
the trigger nine seconds gotta get it in
it's in the hands of Durant
Jeff from the top against Mary Juran
pull-up jumper
see them again
I work out on the coral drills but
pickup is where not home my instincts
for again
Oh
I love being around the atmosphere I
love being around basketball players I
love to hear people talk trash to me
when I'm out in the neighborhood playing
I love it you know that's that's the
best part of someone's need the other
way third rejection
who comes galloping in
rockin the rim go
coming down hard
but it's just a matter of me you know
continue to learn the game and watch and
try to get better each and every day and
not being complacent and I think that's
the biggest thing wanting to be great in
this game is is half and half meant to
and physically maybe more mental than
physical you know so I got to get my
mind right and be able to handle a whole
season and a playoffs you know to be a
good player so but with me is just you
know all about progressive and know what
I need to work on and work on it three
points here what a move by carafe
doggy Collison with the finish have
Levitch is still feeling that I was
historical I think about that run all
the time Oklahoma City is all about on
first off natural disasters in Oklahoma
City bombing just to put it out there to
be real I mean that's what the city was
known for and to win a Western
Conference championship with a group of
young guys by the cities never seen
anything like it it's something I'm
always gonna remember but the Thunder
lost the NBA title to the Miami Heat
and LeBron James in five games Kevin
Durant was second again and there to
console him was the same person who made
him do push-ups in the middle of the
night 12 years earlier he long hug with
your mom after you all didn't make it
there you've hugged her and longing
heart yeah well first thought that was
just like a thank you and my mom that
she was always at the right time
and a lot of people got on me for crying
in front of national TV but we wanted
something that bad it's just like I
didn't care oh hey
packing it on McGhee that old top ten
you know first few games in the playoffs
I was just so excited to be a part that
that atmosphere again and then be back
on that level it was just amazing I
appreciate every single moment you know
we you know just I always revert back to
me being injured because I was first
time something got taken away from me
that I love so much and it just made me
appreciate every moment you know because
we can easily talk about you know the
end result of things but you know the
whole journey you know we talk about the
end result if is not where it should be
then it's a failure but I look at it is
like look man this is an important part
of my life this was something I'm this
memories is some time I was going to
carry it was just it was just great to
be a part of you know to be on the court
playing in that atmosphere again we go
my game Wally has it out front door went
caps into a three for the widow so very
good Kevin the red rises rains and rains
the 28 footer the Sonics winning in
Atlanta you gotta love it to always do
it for love no matter what it is and
work hard it may sound cliche but hard
work really does pay off
and whatever you're doing that's the
model I use you know so you said small
goals and try to reach them and then
that's when big go start to start to
come around and before you know it you
know you'll start to rise on the totem
pole
oh my goodness boy ever couldn't get
there in time on that Durant you look at
that
I just try to make it about the team
making about my teammates is unfair to
the organization and to my teammates to
be distracted you know I had to be the
best me I can be and I think you know I
was proud of how you know I was able to
stay in the moment and I was being a
struggle for me you know as a young
player in this league and so I was
staying conscious of being in the moment
and I was proud I stayed there
especially throughout the playoffs in a
regular season so it was just all about
you know worrying about today
and once tomorrow get there I worry
about that that's always who is that's
who I've been the last few years just
taking it day by day
achieving coach status right now in
Dallas after his last two performances
Durant oh wow
Kevin Durant throws it down my goodness
Kevin Durant says the Brendan Haywood
excuse me I got an appointment with the
rim the odds were stacked against us
single parent with two boys by time we
were 21 years old everybody told us we
weren't supposed to be here we moved
from apartment to apartment by ourselves
one of the best memories I had is when
we moved into our my first apartment no
no bed no furniture and we just all sat
in the living room and just hugged each
other because we that's what we thought
we made it and when something good
happens to you I don't know about you
guys but I tend to look back to what
brought me here and you wake me up in
the middle of the night and the
summertime's
making me run up a hill making me do
push-ups screaming at me from the
sidelines on my games at eight or nine
years old we wasn't supposed to be here
you made us believe you kept us off the
street put clothes on our backs flew the
table when you didn't eat you make sure
we ate you want to sleep hungry you
sacrifice for us you the real MVP
for a sensational
and shot by Kevin Durant that's how you
win games at the buzzer
thank you guys so much for watching we
made this video because Robin Sharma
asked us to if you'd like us to profile
someone else leave a message in the
comments below I'd also love to know
which of the top ten rules meant the
most see you had the biggest impact
leave in the comments and we'll join the
discussion so thank you guys again for
watching continue to believe and we'll
see you soon
my game is based upon be versatile I
think on you know my biggest attribute
is scoring the basketball I think I find
the remnant in different ways that you
know I think I'm a shot maker you know I
could play inside now I'm still working
on both parts of my game I'm far from
where I want to be but you know I think
with my left and my sides I could play
inside and out I think about the future
a lot with steps I have to take now for
us to maybe be a championship team or
what it's going to look like for me in 3
or 4 years we don't be doing we're going
to be at what team I would play for I
never thought I'd be able to impact
people the way I have so far I take
pride in that I'm just a regular guy you
know I played ball on TV sometimes and
knowing that I can give them hope and
inspire them it's been something that's
been like a dream come true